so I'm gonna show you a quick way to
determine if you have brain damage or
not now this is what I don't want you to
do I don't want you to go up to your
friends or your family members and tell
them hey I just saw a video of Dr. Berg's
and I think you have brain damage okay
don't do that this is for you and not
for them what you have to realize is
pretty much everyone acquires some
degree of damage in their brain as they
age and that has to do with a lack of
fuel in your neurons in one study it was
shown that an average person loses about
30 percent of their brain cells as they
get older into their 80s and even 90s
and so that's what I'm talking about
what I'm talking about brain damage so
it's not just dementia it could happen
very gradually like you're looking
for words and you're trying to remember
where you put your keys that type of
thing that is simply a situation where
your neurons are starving of fuel and
the symptoms would be loss of memory
loss of clarity loss of focus and
attention and that comes from doing a
high carbohydrate diet because over time
your body is going to resist the
carbohydrates it's going to create
insulin resistance and now the glucose
can't go into the brain cells and they
starve the good thing about this is that
neurons actually prefer a different type
of fuel not glucose but ketones in fact
if given the choice between glucose and
ketones the brain will always choose
ketones as their preferred fuel so if
your neurons are starving for a glucose
just feed them ketones so now here is
the experiment I would like you to do
simply get on the ketogenic diet and
intermittent fasting I put a link down
below and within one to two weeks notice
your cognitive improvements are you
sharper are you more focused is
memory better and what about you mood
has it gone up if so then we know
there's some level of damage in your
brain or you can try another experiment
you can take MCT oil when you take this
oil medium chain triglycerides comes
from coconuts what's gonna happen is
you're gonna make ketones directly
without even going on a ketogenic diet
and your brain will absorb those ketones
and if there is damage within the brain
your cognitive function will start to
improve you'll be sharper better focus
more attention better memory and even a
better mood so if there's improvement in
either one of these then we know there's
been some damage going on MCT oil
basically gives you instant fuel that
bypasses the damage that the
carbohydrate diet created now one thing
that a lot of people realize when they
start a ketogenic diet and when they
start intermittent fasting is they
start feeling better okay with more
energy and their cognitive function
starts to really improve and definitely
their mood increases so obviously they
stay on the diet for a long period of
time now the cool thing about being on
this program is it can even overtime
improve the damage of your brain rather
than getting a cat scan or MRI of your
brain just simply change the fuel source
and then evaluate it decide if it's
something that you want to do long term
alright thanks for watching and I put
the link down below of how to do the
keto diet as well as intermittent fasting
the correct way thanks for watching with
another amazing recipe no brains no
sugar
totally keto
there's no suffering in Keto absolutely
not Karen and it's an immune system builder
absolutely you have to check this out I
think you should hurry up watch the
recipe and make it yourself it's just so
easy to be keto
but is it simple it's super simple we
hope you enjoy making it as much as we
are enjoying eating it